- I got so drunk that I
participated in the
dancing contest,
(audience laughing)
and I was so drunk that
I won the dance contest.
(dubstep music)
- Welcome to This is
Not Happening presents
One Crazy Night.
So this is what we do,
our bunch of comedians
tell stories about
a similar subject.
So this is just one crazy night.
Ladies and gentlemen,
my friend and yours,
Mr. Doug Benson everybody,
let him hear it.
(audience cheers)
- Hey everybody.
So a long time ago,
I went on a cruise
when I was a young comedian.
It was called the Improv
at Sea, like, Bud Friedman
did this thing where
they did a series
of comedy shows
(audience laughs)
on cruise ships and they change
up the comedians every week
like it was a comedy club and
they even brought in a fake
brick wall
(audience laughs)
that was just made
out of cardboard
that they would just put behind
you so everyone would know
okay yes, this is
stand-up comedy.
We know it is because there's
a brick wall behind you.
(audience laughs)
And they treat you
like a passenger
when you're a comedian
on these cruise ships.
You just have a room with
everybody else and you eat
with everybody, so that's weird
if you have a shitty show.
Like, the next day you're
in line at the buffet
with these people that
didn't get anything
that you were saying
and hated your act.
But they're usually pretty
friendly face-to-face
and they're having a
buffet, so that's exciting.
So...
(audience laughs)
I'm on this cruise ship
and one of the options
you can do during the
day is you can go on
what they call, the
yellowbird cruise.
The idea of the yellowbird
cruise is you get on this big
catamaran thingy and they
take you to a private island
and there's a
place where you can
snorkel and jet-ski and whatnot.
All for extra fees
that keep piling up.
(audience laughs)
In that price you also
got booze, free booze.
And people just get
crazy drinking this
yellowbird punch, they called it
because it was the
yellowbird cruise.
It's like a thousand-proof
or something like that.
I was just throwing them back.
So then we get to the island
and then I do some drunken
snorkeling and
jet-skiing and whatnot.
Which, in retrospect,
was crazy dangerous.
(audience laughs)
And then I get back on
the yellowbird cruise,
and on the way back,
they decide to have
a dance contest.
And I got so drunk that I
participated in
the dance contest.
And I was so drunk, that
I won the dance contest.
(audience applause and laughter)
Thank you very much.
And the prize for
winning the dance contest
was a giant bowl of
yellowbird punch.
(audience laughs)
That they just present to you
and you've got five more
minutes of the ride back to the
boat to drink this giant bowl
of punch, and I obliged them.
So that's pretty much the
last thing that I remember.
(audience laughs)
So...
The rest of the story was
told to me by my friend
Scott, who was also a comedian
on the ship, very funny dude
who started calling my room
when he thought that I was back
on the ship after my excursion.
He got a busy signal and so
eventually he's just like,
well, I'll just go by his
room and see what's up.
It's weird that he hasn't been
able to answer his
phone for a long time.
And he went to my room,
and I was passed out, naked
(audience laughs)
on the bed, on top of
the covers or whatever.
And there was a bottle
of asprin or something
that was dumped over
on the end table.
And the phone was off
the hook, and I was just
laying there, splayed out.
(audience laughs)
And my friend Scott is like,
he was like a huge
practical joker.
So when he walked in on me,
he had a great opportunity.
There's a million jokes
he could've played on me.
And he's the kind of guy that
would smell his own smelly
gym sock, like take a big
whiff of it, and then say,
"This is amazing, this
smells like steak."
(audience laughs)
And then hold it
out for a friend,
and they would
sniff it and he said
one dude almost passed out
from how horrible it was.
(audience laughs)
This is was this guys is like.
And yet, he still just
closed the door to my cabin,
and went back to his cabin and
then told me about it later.
And I still had a good
laugh, though, thinking about
when the cabin door was
swinging open and shut
and all the people that had
seen me do comedy on the ship
were like, cruising by my room
and just seeing...
Seeing my butt hole.
(audience laughs)
Thank you guys so much
for letting me share that.
(audience applause)
(dubstep music)
Enjoy the rest.
- Doug Benson, everybody.
Hi everybody, I hope
you enjoyed the story.
If you did, click
like down there
so that more people
know you liked it.
And don't forget to subscribe,
so that you'll get the next
story as soon as it comes out.